The joe rogan experience and the Olympic Games,
the the,
the event that probably requires more.
Okay.
Transfer of energy and development of kinetic energy than any other,
there's a bunch you could name,
but one of them.
For me,
it's always going to be the,
the javelin throw the javelin throw involves a full pallet sprint,
a jump,
a massive explosive tuning of both hips and shoulders and a throw.
All the quintessential explosive elements of the human body are involved in the
javelins room,
probably to a greater degree than any other Olympic event.
And as a result,
people can throw a javelin 80 90 meters.
What would happen if you took those same javelin throwers and made them perform
the same event on the knees?
Wouldn't be so good.
They probably couldn't throw it more than 10 meters.
Okay,
and what's changed?
The closer they get to the ground,
the less they can employ explosive force.
What's the first thing cowboys do when they go to Brian to steer?
Take it down.
Yeah.
They lock up.
It's the legs and they put it down on the ground.
Nobody tries to brand as standing still.
You're going to get killed because it can employ explosive dynamic movement to
hurt you.
You put them on the ground.
Dynamic explosive movement is massively curtailed.
It takes away the single riskiest element of fighting,
which is quick dynamic movement that can generate kinetic energy.
So step number one,
it was going to do it so it was get it to the ground.
It's inherently safer.
Less things can go catastrophic.
We wrong on the ground and in the standing position.
What step number two?
Secure.
Dominant position control.
Control.
Too vague.
There's many ways to control people.
There's a definite step.
You've just taken a guy down.
What's your first thing and was on units?
Yeah,
well the first thing I would try to do is get to a dominant position.
What do you mean by that?
Being by just pass to side control.
Try to match it.
You just answered it right.
Then get pastas,
legs,
passes legs.
Why?
It's legs are strong.
I carry you around.
You could hold a person in position.
They,
they're very good defensively.
They dangerous.
Too dangerous.
If I end up inside your legs,
if you're a skilled,
juicy play,
you can unlock me.
Can Lake Lock me,
can strangle me even if you were an untrained,
funny,
you could up kick me.
Right.
Mania man has been knocked out by an upkick.
Even an untutored guy can pull it up,
get sure lakes are dangerous.
So step number two is get pasta.
Those dangerous lakes.
What state number three?
Go for submission.
No,
he must be a 10th planet belt.
So yeah,
I hate to throw that in some rigid.
Oh,
I'm um,
it's,
it's one of those things like it has to be regulated.
It has to be protected and it has to be guaranteed as a thing for human beings.
Not even just Americans.
Well,
it's just,
it's stunning to me how many people are against the idea of having an open
internet.
Yeah.
Well,
you know,
most of the polling,
I think polls are always,
you gotta be careful,
right?
Because they can ask a question one way and get an answer.
But the best one done was right before our boat by the University of Maryland,
found 83% of the public supported net neutrality opposed what we were doing.
But who are those 17% dummies?
That's what I want to know.
I think anything you can get the American public to agree to at 83% is a pretty,
I think it's wonderful but I'm stunned [inaudible] 17% yeah,
seriously.
But isn't there a bunch of people?
There's some,
and I,
I wrote about this on Twitter recently without judgment.
I said that net neutrality seems to me to be one of those ideological issues
where um,
if you're on the right you support it or if you're on the left rather you
support it where you're on the right,
you would like it to go away.
So almost like totally disagree with,
okay,
please do.
If you are
a democrat or a Republican,
you benefit from net neutrality and internet openness.
If you're conservative or liberal.
If you're a big business or a small business,
you benefit from Internet openness.
And the history of net neutrality is something that doesn't get discussed
enough,
which is that it began the first time the FCC put net neutrality policy on
paper.
It was 2005 and I'm old enough to remember that that was when President George
W.
Bush was in the White House.
In other words,
this country's first net neutrality policies were put on paper one a republican
was running the FCC.
It is only in recent days.
We have characterize this as a left right issue and I think that's a
fundamentally a mistake.
How did it happen like when when Ajit Pi proposes legislation and passed it,
it baffled me.
I thought net neutrality was a thing we had all agreed on.
It was like,
we're never touching this.
How did this happen?
Oh,
well,
you know,
through a whole bunch of boring Washington
seizures whereby they circulate out of proposed rulemaking or how did,
how did he get the power and leverage to pass this?
I think that he was supported by people in Washington,
including some broadband providers and was led to believe that with deregulation
we would all be better off
being away from race car driving.
When you deciding at just like enough is enough,
do you think that in some ways that this is,
you appreciating other aspects of life too that you,
you're,
you're looking at your racing thing and you're like,
you know what,
I did a lot,
I did enough and then why don't I just appreciate all the other stuff?
Well,
I think that's a good question.
A lead to me into a good thought.
Like,
um,
I think it's actually more
being honest.
Like I think everyone would expect since I do what I do at the level that I do
it at,
the racing is my only thing I care about.
I love it so much.
I'll do anything I drive every day.
And the truth is no,
I like racing,
but I don't,
there's a lot of things I don't really like about it too and I'm grateful for
everything it's given me.
But if you were to ask me what I do outside of racing and my personal life,
I don't go to the race track.
I don't really watch races.
I don't,
I don't do that.
So those aren't my hobbies.
Like your hobbies or your real loves,
what do you not like about it?
Um,
well I would say that in the last year or so,
the,
just the,
as far as an energetic space,
it's just so sad and negative at t a lot of the time.
And even in just racing in general,
most of the time it's miserable.
Like you'd have some days that are good,
but most of the time it's not happy and you wish there was,
you're,
you're on.
You're not satisfied.
You wish somebody would have treated you better out there.
You,
there's so many things to be negative about and just the grind of it.
Um,
it's the people like everybody's worn out and you know,
you have to be really careful about the people that are around you because
they've got to be in a good mood because it's easy to spiral out of control
because you see each other for three,
four days a week,
every week for 40 weeks a year.
So,
you know,
you gotta be in a good space with people,
but it still doesn't alienate you completely.
Even if there,
you're in a good space with people that the ones next to you,
cause you got a car next to you on both sides in the garage and haulers next to
each other and buses right next to each other and you see a bunch of other
people.
So,
you know,
it was just,
I don't know,
there's a lot of negativity to some degree.
Um,
a lot of grind.
It just kind of feels like the grind a little bit.
Um,
and um,
so I just kind of felt like it wasn't a space that I wanted to be in as much
anymore.
Like,
I,
I want to be in a happy space where I'm just doing things that bring me joy.
And um,
yeah,
it just,
there wasn't doing that as much or I was noticing it,
I was noticing I was missing that or wanting it more.
I think that's really what it comes from is growing as a person and realizing,
um,
I think everybody's afraid to take chances and do something new in their life
because they're identified a certain way or there'll be judged if they don't do
it or judged if they do something different and who are they now and are they
crazy and what are they thinking?
And you know,
it's just life.
Just do things that make you happy.
In his case,
his kidneys were in trouble and his heart was in trouble.
And the cells,
they don't,
unlike what we used to think in the early days,
they don't become anything.
These kinds of,
this kind of stem cell does not become anything in your body,
but at home,
areas of that need repair and it secretes things that stimulates the repair and
decrease the inflammation and helps out with the immune system.
So the vast majority of what we treat or autoimmune diseases.
And um,
in,
in Hud's case,
we gave him ivs so that,
that he could basically have these
things on board.
So creating the,
the secreting the cytokines and the,
and the growth factors that are normally secreted.
And when you're 92 and you have multiorgan failure,
you're basically running on fumes.
And so you put these days zero young healthy cells and they secrete these things
that kind of restarts everything.
Yeah.
And so what was his response to this Ivy Treatment?
Wow.
Uh,
I,
you know,
I could,
I can wax lyrical about that.
He's almost a hundred years old and,
uh,
from pretty bad shape.
It was like bee stings.
It was like he got a new lease of life.
Like he got a big dose locally in the hip,
which a fixed all his inflammation and pain.
And he started walking again,
and his kidneys were good.
And his heart,
he had a prolapse valves in there and they healed.
And,
uh,
his,
um,
cognitive powers improved.
His eyesight improved.
Whoa.
You know,
and other stuff improved that I ate.
He would hate me to talk about it,
but he had two nurses that reported to me and it was like,
holy mackerel,
that's using it as a towel rack,
you know?
Yeah.